oh opponent gave me more time opponent
wants to beat me fair and square and not
flag me the problem is I can't really do
much unless I can I'm going to have to
give away my queen this is not good
though maybe it's not so bad I can take
that's so nice a oppon is so generous I
I get anxious when I fall below 10
minutes and then anxiety goes away I'm
just trying to calculate the best course
of action I think A6 no A6 is no good
let's take and play King
C6 idea Bishop D6 I'm not going to be as
generous and no extra time for my
opponent no free rook for my opponent
ooh what wait what just happened
ah opened up the source code okay ooh
this is really bad I'm Bishop beautiful
[Music]
Bishop okay